I mean you are so beautifully tall I
wish thank you but my mom would be like
thank me
so five kids and running your own
business is like I have a lot of job so
we have four kids I have no idea how
you're doing it yeah it's crazy
yeah good but no you just every lunch
actually baby bad yes your daughter's
which I wanted a baby fat piece when I
when it first came out I was like
obsessed with it I couldn't buy it
because my parents and then when it we
like sort of reemerged as this well you
can buy it
I took a try was shooting in New York
and I took a special trip to go get it
and then the line was already sold out
the riaf whip oh yeah forever yeah and
it was gone I was all gone that was our
launch the only thing that was left was
those pink velour tube tops I was like
could I pull it that question anymore
just know so but Yuri lunch though with
your daughters how is that with your
daughter so Ming and I okie my okie 17
they're both in college Mingus just
turned 20 so this is she's 17 in college
she's at Harvard one of the youngest
ever yeah
like things do you think like any you're
working with your daughters and it's a
big thing for women like do you think
that I don't know like fashion is is
lacking still and like representation
and how do you think you're doing better
I think we're doing better but I
definitely feel like it's lacking for
women and women of color and I've been
in the business over 25 years and women
are shut out I mean obviously okay if
you're a model that's fine but what
comes after that you're shut out of all
the business all the finance making
choices you know being creative really
we've come a long way but we have so
much so much further to go and I think
that's important for my kids to already
have a job they kind of grew up you know
I tell them you better get a scholarship
you better do something to help me yeah
and so they know like every little bit
you know use your voice use your
creativity chase your passion I think so
so important yeah I tell me our
lifestyle places I'm like well we have
the money and I'm like Oh sweetie
you have no money I am spending all of
this you better be prepared to work I'm
spending every dime I cannot take it
with me you better get to work okay well
we have a 12 year old fashion designer
backstage whose dream is to grow up to
be just like Kimora a fashion icon she
has no idea Kimora is here and that Kors
got a very special proposal at her
stylish Lee well one sleep today will
meet her neck check out these looks
right here so these outfits were
designed by that young girl modeling
them all right so at 12 years old she
can already say she's a fashion designer
with her own brand and a growing list of
exclusive clients from Soulfly skies say
hello to Skyler Johnson
you are looking so fantastic and let me
walk down here and I was like I was here
12 and I have never been that cool like
I have never been that cold like how did
you get into designing clothes oh when I
was eight I was just sitting on the
couch watching Disney Channel like most
eight year olds more in 37 year olds
with toddlers yes go and deaf camera and
she was doing a segment where she was
like upcycling and she would go to the
fifth stores and you know take some
stuff that she like liked and she'd take
him home and like put amira and spit on
it so I was like oh that's really cool
maybe I should do that
so me and my mom cleaning out my closet
I was like mom I don't wanna give away
my clothes
I want to upcycle room so she's like
what's up cycling so I told her what it
was and she wrote me with inprivate
sewing lessons that's so great
okay tell you what I wasn't doing at
eight being that cool being that cool
I'm certain you are getting some big
clients oh so tell us about Phyllis so
Phyllis Randall she is the chairwoman of
Aden County my mom she's like so Phyllis
Randall just called me and she wants you
to make her outfit and I was just like
[Music]
okay see I mean were you terrified /
excited or both yes okay I was like I
was I think 10 that's incredible
[Applause]
amazing it is but not normal it is it's
like you're leaps and bounds ahead of
all other people your age okay I do have
a surprise for Skylar we have someone
here who has blown the fashion and
beauty world away she's a model the
woman behind baby fat and so many other
successful businesses Kimora Lee Simmons
come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
kind of crazy like how many of your kids
probably grew up or in a bit you didn't
grow up in this industry so well first
of all your kid this is not normal it's
awesome it's like so crazy because I
have kids of all ages and I just think
you are mind blowing mine are too I love
you
perfect it's so perfect everything is
roses but what do you what do you think
of her designs like what she's I saw
them I think they're beautiful I'm cute
you made them and you and you modeled
them and I was like wait she did that
they were like yeah she did I saw some
of your sketches and it wait and how old
is she
it's crazy mind-blowing I mean you also
have a surprise for her as well right
yes so I gave you I brought you a little
something here and we just want to tell
you I want to tell you but I'm sure
everybody wants to tell you how proud we
are of you and how important it is for
you to follow your dreams and never let
anybody tell you what you can't do
because of what you look like or your
shape or your size or your color or your
age which they try to do for me a lot so
if you would be willing I would like to
accept you under my wing and offer you a
mentor
[Applause]
keep in touch and you can design you
know things and show me your sketches
I'm a good boss that's it or not and
then you can meet the girls and kind of
coach you along through on your fashion
journey she's gone and she's like you're
super fantastic I'm so happy that she
was here and wanted to mentor you
excited yes yes yes I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this